Oi pessoal tudo bem Hoje o vídeo vai ser
um tanto diferente eu não estou aqui
para falar de saúde diretamente mas
sobre a saúde desse canal que
construímos juntos ao longo dos anos
então eu preciso muito compartilhar algo
importante com vocês e ouvir a opinião
de cada um Imaginem trabalhar por mais
de 8 anos em algo com todo seu coração e
de repente perceber que tudo está
desmoronando aos poucos bom é exatamente
assim que eu estou me sentindo hoje ao
ver o que está acontecendo com esse
canal nos últimos 24 meses
aproximadamente 2 anos temos perdido
muita relevância Então as visualizações
estão caindo isso é algo que me preocupa
bastante no começo eu confesso eu achei
que o problema fosse o famoso Shadow
buan para quem não sabe o Shadow buan
acontece quando a plataforma limita o
alcance dos seus vídeos sem te avisar e
eu cheguei a acreditar que isso estava
realmente acontecendo por causa de
algumas das minhas opiniões mais
polêmicas mais contra o sistema
especialmente desde 2020 por causa do
c19 então de fato tinha evidência de que
isso estava acontecendo não era
simplesmente uma impressão minha mas com
o tempo eu fui percebendo que essa não
era a única explicação outra coisa que
aconteceu foi a mudança do algoritmo do
YouTube o YouTube começou a dar
prioridade para vídeos curtos e e com
grande potencial de viralização muito
influenciado Pelo sucesso tiktok então
aqui no canal Eu Sempre tentei trazer
para vocês conteúdos mais aprofundados
mais detalhados mas nem sempre isso
prende atenção logo nos primeiros
segundos de vídeo isso é algo que o
algoritmo da plataforma atualmente leva
muito em conta e qual que é o resultado
disso meus vídeos começaram a ser
entregues para menos e menos pessoas
agora tem uma outra questão que é mais
específica do nicho saúde então
Diferentemente de outros temas como
viagens ou política a saúde acaba sendo
muito mais segmentada eu vou dar um
exemplo para vocês uma pessoa pode
chegar aqui no canal procurando
informações sobre uma doença específica
como enxaqueca mas essa mesma pessoa
pode não se interessar por um outro tema
um outro vídeo meu que fala por exemplo
sobre fibromialgia isso é bem diferente
de um canal de viagens onde uma pessoa
interessada Por Um Destino pode querer
ver outros vídeos sobre outros lugares o
mesmo acontece com canais de política
quando alguém se alinha uma visão tende
a assistir vários vídeos do mesmo
criador porque ele torce por aquele
assunto no nosso caso a pessoa busca
resolver um problema específico de saúde
e quando isso é resolvido ela pode não
ter interesse em outros vídeos do canal
isso naturalmente impacta muito o nosso
engajamento e aqui entra uma autocrítica
importante e um pedido de desculpas Será
que que na tentativa de tornar o canal
mais popular e acessível eu acabei me
afastando da Minha Essência que fez
tantos de vocês se inscreverem no começo
eu lembro muito bem de como eu comecei
eram vídeos mais longos mais científicos
e sem tanta preocupação com a
apresentação eu era um médico apaixonado
pelo que eu fazia Continuo sendo mas
naquela época era com uma câmera tremida
e muitos vício de linguagem Mas vocês
estavam ali comigo e o canal foi
crescendo crescendo crescendo aão
questão é que com o tempo com o passar
do tempo eu fui tentando simplificar as
coisas tornar a linguagem mais acessível
e tentar ser mais comunicativo será que
ao tentar alcançar um público maior eu
acabei me perdendo nesse processo essa é
a pergunta então nos últimos anos eu fiz
várias tentativas de mudar o formato dos
vídeos tentei coisas mais criativas
algumas até
disruptivas mas até agora nenhuma dessas
abordagens dessas tentativas trouxe o
resultado que eu esperava recuperar a
relevância e E pior algumas dessas
mudanças causaram estranhamento em
vários de vocês que estavam acostumados
com o estilo mais tradicional do canal e
eu percebo que não fui bem sucedido em
agradar a maioria e para mim é difícil
admitir isso mas a verdade é que a
motivação para mim para eu continuar tá
muito baixa tem diminuído bastante o
canal tem mais de 800.000 inscritos mas
a média de visualizações está muito a
quem muito abaixo do esperado eu comparo
com outros canais menores de nichos
diferentes e eu vejo que muitos têm um
engajamento maior até muito maior do que
o meu e aí vem a pergunta o que que eu
estou fazendo de errado Será que a saúde
como um todo como nicho Será que o
problema que ela tá saturada ou será que
a minha forma de comunicar não está
conseguindo prender a atenção de vocês
bom é aqui que eu preciso da sua ajuda
preciso da sua opinião sincera o que que
você acha será que é hora de encerrar
seja sincero porque se não for isso eu
Provavelmente vou reduzir drasticamente
a minha produção aqui nesse canal e de
vez em quando eu vou soltar um vídeo aí
mais científico tipo o aulão de
PowerPoint no meu outro canal e esse
vídeo esses vídeos futuros vão ser muito
mais focados nos Profissionais de Saúde
eu realmente quero ouvir o que você
pensa porque esse canal é uma missão
para mim mas sem vocês sem vocês
assistindo os vídeos ele não faz mais
sentido para mim Eu já pedi várias vezes
para vocês compartilharem os vídeos com
seus amigos seus familiares Mas uma
parcela muito pequena de fato faz isso
talvez seja Porque de fato os meus
vídeos não mereçam ser compartilhados eu
tenho que aceitar essa possibilidade e
eu digo isso de coração por mais que eu
me esforce para trazer aqui um conteúdo
de qualidade para vocês Talvez eu tenha
me perdido em algum ponto do caminho no
começo os vídeos eram muito mais longos
mais científicos uma pegada diferente
até com aqueles vícios de linguagem que
eu já mencionei conforme o canal foi
crescendo eu tentei fazer vídeos mais
curtos mais relevantes para populares
digamos assim será que foi aí que eu
errei nessa mudança de abordagem agora
estou realmente considerando reduzir
bastante a frequência dos vídeos isso é
quase certo ou quem sabe até encerrar a
produção do canal mas antes de tomar
qualquer decisão eu preciso saber o que
que vocês pensam então deixe seu
comentário aqui embaixo nunca foi tão
importante você comentar eu vou ler
todos os comentários com muito carinho
muita atenção vocês podem realmente
ajudar a decidir o futuro desse canal no
final a verdade é que assim como na
saúde às vezes precisamos de um checkup
de uma pausa para reavaliar o caminho da
nossa vida e nesse caso o caminho Desse
Canal esse é o nosso momento de
diagnóstico e juntos quem sabe podemos
encontrar a melhor saída para esse canal
para que ele continu sendo útil para
vocês mas mesmo que eu pare de fazer
vídeos eu assumo compromisso de manter
os vídeos antigos vai continuar com os
vídeos disponíveis antigos pelo menos os
que não foram ainda censurados pela
plataforma Obrigado por estarem aqui
comigo Conto com a ajuda de vocês e quem
sabe se seja o começo de um novo
capítulo na nossa jornada até a próxima
E como sempre pessoal você é fera um
grande abraço e um beijo no seu coração